I shot a gun at 9 years old in the meat
of the loud guns you cannot hear your
gun and that sometime can be terrifying
so you'll come to your conscious by
seeing your gun shaking that's when you
know it's actually working
Emanuel jowl was a child soldier during
the brutal Sudanese Civil War in the
1990s where government forces in the
predominantly Muslim North fought rebels
in the South taken from his home he was
beaten brainwashed and trained by the
rebels to fight after four years of
fighting he managed an epic escape to
create a new life mr. Chou was sent to
train to be a soldier at the age of
eight by his father who was the rebels
Chief of Police the training was brutal
we were welcomed with a beatin the
violence that was given to us I can't
even describe it I look at it as a
psychological way to break into us so
they can mold us to what they want he
survived the training and was given a
gun ready for revenge that ward of the
soul of my village and my aunt is died
during that war all my uncle's died
during that war my mother was claimed by
that war as a kid I wanted two things to
get a bike I wanted to get a bicycle and
also to kill as many Arabs and Muslims
as possible mr. Joe and the other boys
had been groomed to feel a sense of
camaraderie to fight for each other at
first the violence was exciting the beat
of the ak-47 itself
is so empowering violence is fun there's
an excitement when they give you a gun
into your hand you're excited memories
from childhood can be hazy and some have
disputed mr. Giles claims but he says
after four years of fighting he escaped
the rebel commanders in the dead of
night he and 400 other child soldiers
fled if they were recaptured they would
have almost certainly been killed the
boy is trekked for three months across
the country facing starvation I call
this the lowest point I've ever been
because we drunk our own urine other
soldiers started eating dead bodies one
of the escapees managed to reach a
village and raise the alarm mr. Joe says
only 16 of the 400 boys survived
we got rescued and I met a British aid
worker call Emma McCune and she's the
one that smuggled me through a plane
into Kenya and that became the turning
point of my life well was able to go to
school mrs. McCune was married to mr.
Giles uncle the rebel leader react masha
she died in a car crash shortly
afterwards so mr. Joe had to make his
own way as a teenager in the Kenyan
slums but something saved him as a way
of dealing with the trauma he had
experienced he started rapping and
discovered hip-hop I got into music
because I saw music was the place I were
to become a challenging
in 2004 his debut album was a hit in
Kenya the single appeared on a UK
charity album and he played at Nelson
Mandela's 90th birthday concerts in the
last decade mr. Joe has travelled the
world performing and sharing his
experiences through his music with the
likes of Alicia Keys and Nelly Furtado
he uses his music to be a political
activist and peace advocate the
challenges that are being true I
accepted them I accepted my childhood
experience every person who has become
successful
has got a little fire mr. Joe is one of
the lucky ones
according to the UN tens of thousands of
children have been recruited as child
soldiers across 20 countries this year
alone children place should be school
children should be taught to love should
be taught to explore the imagination not
to be trained to kill people not to be
exposed to violence